good morning everybody and welcome to
the referrals meeting today a referrals
meeting is made up of members of both
committees a and B gives us more
opportunity to have more views my name
is Cathy Guthrie and I'm the chairman
today mayor first of all remind you of
some domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs can I just ask can
you hear me oh dear that's unusual for
me cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
is that better thank you if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so
please switch off mobile phones or turn
them to silent and I will have to do
that shortly I would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the Internet and
will be capable of repeated viewing and
I am advised that the sound is working
when it wasn't the other day so
hopefully everything should be working
today the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and training
purposes the council members of the
public and press may record film or
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded finally can members
and officers please ensure that you
press the microphone for speaking and
turned off when you have finished so
make the introductions now on my left we
have in Despres our legal advisor
we have Phillip is vavle who's
chief planning officer I'd like to give
them all sorts of names but that's one
of them
chief planning officer and that's fine
that's me and then we have Rob
Carmichael our officer and we then have
Joe who will be presenting the case and
we have Henriette who will be driving
the internet we have ladies and
gentlemen sitting to my left of which
are from different console tees Suffolk
County Council Planning and
infrastructure we have Neill McManus and
to his third right at left we have Peter
freer and in the middle we have Peter
Mumford schools and infrastructure Sam
Harvey is down here from highways and we
have Christine Thurlow sitting over at
the back there sill and 106 and we've
got Tom Barker director of the mid
soffit and planning we have your good
selves who are sitting in the public
area of which some of you may have
elected to speak you would have three
minutes which we have here we also have
one little lone person sat here who's
the ward member she can speak but not
vote but most importantly we have the
elected members who are of our committee
who will debate and decide the outcome
today so without further ado can we move
on to the agenda please apologies for
absence and substitutions Thank You
chair
we have apologies from councillor
Humphreys councillor Mansell councillor
mayor and council Norris thank you to
receive any declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest by members
councillor Muller and councillor eben
sorry you a second thank a chair on the
vice-chair of the stone Market Town
Council Planning Committee Thank You
Rachel
it's a Hopkins Holmes development and my
brother used to work for Hopkins Holmes
but doesn't anymore thank you very much
for that declarations of lobbying yes I
think we've all received the same thing
thank you I mean your permission just
comment on
not only was I lobbied by a letter I
then got a phone call to see if I'd
received the letter and open the letter
I think that's a step too far I don't
think the applicant should be calling
members at home on top of her sending
letters so just want to formally lodge
that I think that's unsatisfactory I
think that's a very fair point thank you
and our legal advisor we can go that's
my counselor Hicks that was the
applicant not an object to your right
just to be absolutely clear thank you
declarations of personal site visits you
know maybe we have confirmation of
minutes of the meeting so just to let
members know with regards to miss they
do to the turnaround time between the
last meeting the shortness of as members
will be aware of the calling of this
meeting and own personal illness from my
part I'm afraid of minutes weren't
available to bring forward to the
committee today so apologies but they
will be here on the 31st which is our
next set noted thank you to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the counselors petition scheme none
received here thank you and the schedule
of planning applications is the one that
we have starting on page 11 and we have
Joe who will be presenting this case
today just before we start I think mr.
Isabel just wanted to give us a few
extra bits of information thank you
Thank You chairman yes just two it's not
in late papers
I received an email us at four o'clock
from Joe Churchill MP and I think it's
appropriate for me to be there verbatim
so that you have that and that email
concerns this meeting it says dear
Philip I would like before the planning
meeting at 9:30 a.m. tomorrow morning to
make you aware of the strong feeling
about Hopkins development of 300 houses
in Woolpit as per my discussions with
Suzy Morley leader of ms DC and Arthur
chavo Nia MS DC CEO last Friday I
outlined to them in the strongest
possible terms that planning was
Norma's concern to residents in and
around Thurston bullpit holy
Elmas well old Newton and whether done
in particular as we discussed these
settlements are on or close to the a14
and therefore understandably attractive
attractive to speculative developers
however I outlined my concerns around
land banking and the fact that build-out
rates appear not to be in line with
planning consent granted
additionally the continued lack of
clarity over the five-year land supply
is potentially living too much scope for
self interpretation there is also
potential for better liaison with
Suffolk County Council on infrastructure
and arguing more pressure to be applied
to developers for infrastructure type
and tenure of build more consideration
of the use of environmentally friendly
build processes should also be taken
into account it has been noted that the
timeline of the planning application and
the apparent delay of the neighborhood
plan in ballpit has led to a breakdown
in trust and confidence something this
process is meant to enhance further I
know at the village within their
neighborhood plan has allocated a
housing site for 250 homes and I will be
seeking clarity whether if tomorrow's
application is approved this will be
left as green space I'm sure like me you
would want this process to be as
transparent as possible thank you Jim
thank you but we will now move on and
Joe if you would present the case thank
you very much Thank You chair so the
application before members today as this
outline application submitted by Hopkins
Holmes and will put to the north of the
village and the proposal is for 300
Wellings
and also site for primary school and
preschool
extension to existing burial ground and
cemetery village car park and highway
improvements to Junction 47 of the a14
along with open space ecology
improvements and other infrastructure
the application is an outline form but
access is to be determined today and the
spine Road which I'll show you in later
slides is a fixed location and so that
would be approved as shown in the plans
and members are considering today so
wolf it is a key service center in
current mid Suffolk core strategy that
looks to direct majority of new
development in the district to their
housing employment and suchlike
this is the site outlined in red stands
at twenty three point four hectares to
the top of the slide you will see the
a14 and the historic core pulpits down
here and we'll go through the
constraints in more detail for the
slides so here we are and we've got a
video of the site is to give members
context the video starts here with a
green dot on the a14 slip read of
Junction 47 and we're going to go around
the south into the village and South
site and end it right there
episode by telnet and Road so to start
the video
[Applause]
okay so we just come into off the a14
Limassol note as we get to the end of
the slip road we get to the t-junction
to turn left into wall pit and you'll be
able to see symp mary's church in the
distance there we go the spire just
there sorry funky pop on the video there
it is and so now we are just heading
down the side of this slide here past
existing commercial uses on the left of
the slide so we have gold star transport
on the left and then just go to the way
to the village sorry this circle video
we can't speed it up but we just want to
make sure members have a full
appreciation of all the site and looking
right there and Cricket pavilions
cricket pitch we've just gone past we're
just heading down to the junction with
Church Street which video will turn
right into shortly I think one things
points out back that the early part of
the slide as well was the vegetation
that's a different screening of the site
we will look at that further in photos
as well too so you can see that as a
still around from the video so here we
are turning into Church Street and going
to the historic core of war pet that
service station aside as we go down a
soup Mary's Church great one listed
building just comes interview there it's
one of the key heritage assets which
will are explained later in the
presentation the impact of the
derailment on that heritage asset
and there are no other development sites
to the left and currently one scheme
being built out down that road there and
again I'll have another slide is to show
the existing context of planning
applications in ballpit sometimes you
can see that wider context as well so
we're just coming out of the development
here at the red dot on the slide in the
historic core and then we miss we move
further along we'll get to more recent
modern development which bounds the
south to the site as well and the site
will start to be visible on the right
here now so you get views across the
site just here and on the left is
Wright's way which will be the access
one of the access roundabout points I'll
show you a more detailed plan shortly of
that and we'll just work our way around
turn right up white to calm Road here
and just go to the top of this point
here and just on the left there of that
slide which will put business centre
that's one that all the mention nation
presentation as well so here we've got
developing the left of white elm lane
some intermediate vegetation on the
right-hand side and the development site
here on the right
and that'll end shortly and we'll go
onto the next video which is slightly
shorter
okay
so this video here comes from starts on
Church Street and then turns right down
rectory lane and goes up to the
community center which is the south of
the application site so again we've got
sick Mary's Church the distance sir
and again it's just some context of the
surrounding development to the south the
sites will historic moment also with
more modern interventions within the
surrounding area as well and here we
have the car park with the beam Center
which she's filmed on a very busy day
okay this next video looks starts here
actually Lane and then comes back down
the other way quickly play that one just
to show the the view from the other
direction so you can really get an
appreciation of what's to the south of
the application site and I will show you
on a later slide the extent of the
conservation area which we're currently
going through as well and it's the video
here this aims to show the setting of
the church Roger to the shaky camera
angle I think the intention was to try
and give an appreciation of that church
setting and the more modern development
which is also within the setting of that
church
okay and then lastly we're going to have
a video the opposite way around just so
we can see the development site from
white down Lane and then up to the
junction at the a40 the age on Form 247
at the a14 so again I will show you
photos of this sites more clearly so you
can see st. Mary's Church within the
context that around the site ex-officio
so the video is a little bit difficult
to see that I'll come to those photos
shortly
just while we're here just to say the
ballpit business center business parks I
see on the right of this video the
moment as I said earlier and there is a
weight restriction 7.5 tonnes within the
village center for lorries traveling
through so here of the application site
on the Left vegetation shown there the
location of the access to the south of
site which I'll show you on the latest
slide and then we're just traveling back
into the historic core of Woolpit
yes yes sorry the video is a little bit
slave obviously speed is essential to
break the speed limit okay this is our
last video then we have a little bit of
error photography of the site just to
show the context of the site and a bit
more detail it's probably important to
point out at this point you'll see the
road is now here we have parking on the
road and there was the weight limit
restriction within bullpit but obviously
a traffic from the business centre
that's under 7.5 x could use this route
through the village and I'll come on to
that later with this proposed spying
Road and the timing of the delivery of
that's why Road
so on the left here we have the cricket
ground sports pitches and the cricket
cricket battles to the north the site
that directly adjoins the application
site and I'll show you the proposals how
that relates to the application site
shortly and against point out the
vegetation even in winter here you can
see there's quite significant vegetation
lines along the site and I'll show you
plans of the hedgerows to be retained
and the landscaping proposed shortly so
here we are is coming back up to the
employment areas on the right and about
to come up to the t-junction where
traffic traveling westbound on the a14
comes in - okay and this video and just
as you get to the bridge of the a14 or
you need to access it to travel
eastbound
okay all right so here is a video of the
site that it going to go into so now
photography with a 14 Junction 47 that
t-junction their applications that's
just off the plan but if we just start
the video hope you fly in is the cricket
pitch here and here's the application
site the green field and the video will
move on site and then focus on st.
Mary's Church shortly so you can see
that context so it's the entirety of
this slightly walk green field as
opposed to the yellow field it's not
showing what Elm Road and now it's going
to zoom into the city Mary's Church
very good you see the letters roof there
and also just to points out here we've
also got grade ii listed building months
close just adjacent to the application
site and as I said the conservation area
extent which I'll show you a plan on
shortly and then just this video shows
the proposed access spying Road where it
will come out and how it will relate to
the existing Junction 47 or appear on
the slide shortly which when I show you
the proposals hopefully will make sense
this is the proposed roundabout at this
Junction to replace the existing T
Junction and that offshoot there's the
spy.road into the application site so
when I show you the band's Hopi that
will come alive and make sense so just
to show the heritage assets now of the
scheme we have several vista buildings
and a conservation area that we need to
have regard to so church here's outlined
you might just come up here and within
that setting of the church there are a
number of existing buildings these
aren't all listed these are just
pointing out where the existing
buildings are I pointed out grade two
star great to mulch close building here
these are not listed and she shows
significant intervening vegetation
that's what the yellow shows and then
the extent of the sightless in the
conservation areas as shown in that
brown and white hatched area there
that's the conservation area boundary
and once it comes down the cross sea and
historic cool i'll show you the full
extent later but that's the only part of
the site that is in the conservation
area so to show some constraints sites a
little bit more detailed we've got the
site here outlines an orange hatched and
pink and then just to point out also the
conservation area is shown in purple so
just to the south of where i'm hovering
the red dot and i'll see around the
around the village just the above the
red dot i'm probably now as monks close
I pointed out great teal Lister building
and the grade one is the church just
there and also just to point out we've
got the gray two listed church in Elms
well I'll show you photos at across the
site shortly as well so we're just there
so this is the application site we said
appraisal shortly or see excluding the
cricket ground which is just where I'm
hovering now this is their plan from our
emerging joint local plan I just want to
cover the joint length plan and the ball
pit made to the plan in these next
couple of slides so we've got our
application site in red which forms part
of the wider sites being promoted in the
joint local plan so we have the proposal
for 300 on this red line but the
allocation is for 500 in total we also
have proposed allocations here it's been
granted outline planning consent and
full planning consent here is the site
that was allowed at Appeal and we have
two other sites here we just also
highlighted on this site here at this
plan here that the neighborhood plan
looks to allocate this site and that
site and I will show you that in more
detail in a second members of C knee to
have cautioned how much weight they
place on the joint local plan at present
as it is merging it has limited weight
but it is obviously a large body of work
that looks at the housing requirements
across the district as a whole and there
was a large body of evidence on
infrastructure that goes in to inform
that that picture and the JLP looks
identified the most sustainable sites in
the district it's a it's an exercise to
try and find where the best location for
growth is which gives an indication on
the sustainability credentials of this
site it's a direction of travel this
document at present but obviously has a
limited weight for the purposes of this
decision-making process today I just
want to point out the evidence behind it
particularly in relation to planning for
infrastructure for the planned growth
that the council is looking to achieve
moving on to the walpert neighbor plan
the neighborhood plan has just had its
submission consultation which glows a
couple of weeks ago and the timetable is
looking next to move to examination at
present in planning terms the
neighborhood plan has limited weights
now this doesn't disregard the amount of
work and
effort that they group bringing the plan
forward has to put into that but we just
need to be mindful that in a planning
legal sense we can only give it a
limited way to present that doesn't
disregard to the work that's gone into
it
say it's just the way we have to legally
interpret that plan at present
once the examiner's report is received
they want to have more significant
weight so just to run through the
allocations of see the site we're
looking at today and it's not put
forwards in the neighborhood plan
there's one additional site here for 40
dwellings and extension to walk with
primary school which the joint local
plan is not looking to allocate but then
the other two sites which I pointed out
me on the slide they are the same as the
emerging joint know can plan the there
are also some issues which members will
see in late papers the council has
responded to officers have responded to
the Wolcott neighborhood plan raising
issues with the housing requirement
identified in the walk wit neighborhood
plan obviously there's a discrepancy the
joint local plan looks to allocate more
housing than the Wolcott neighborhood
plan and that as the matter that has
been raised to the ball pit neighborhood
plan group but just to point out that
there is that issue at the moment
discrepancy between the two and that's
the matter that will play out to an
examination and isn't for us to discuss
and determining there's planning
application today but just to draw
members attention to the inclusion of
that document in the late papers so just
to give the context the wider area and
then we'll get into the details of the
proposal for members today here we have
the site a 14 notable feature when said
landscape and Elms well to the north
east the site and here we have just a
bit more annotations of the site the
context I think I've probably discussed
most of these streets we have actually
Lane we saw videos up and the street and
then we went up to a whitetail Road and
here's the Business Park I referred to
and I was sitting Industrial Estate here
which the Planning Commission was issued
in 2019 for further industrial land here
and I hope to Elms well and we have the
1088
the road that comes down through past
Wolcott so here is the proposed land use
and sort of the outline stage so
indicative that this parameter plan
would be broadly adhered to in the
reserved matters stage I'll just quickly
run through it like there's a better
slice that show it in more detail so we
have the residential and pink open space
and that bluey color here we have the
extensions the existing burial cemetery
ground which follows the extent of the
Conservation Area here we have open
space which is looking to be transferred
to the Cricket Club and here we have the
village car park which is highlighted in
green and here we have the spire Road
but I'll show it to you in a later slide
as that shows a little bit more detail
and that's is the indicative Institute
if master founders to demonstrate that
three hundred Wellings could be
accommodated on the site with all the
other land take requirements such as
sustainable drainage features and the
primary school site which is two point
two hectares here so just to go around
their plan a little bit more detail we
have in the northwest plan steps water
features here and here open space
indicated and this is the junction a new
roundabout with Wright's way just to the
south the access here we have in yellow
the school sites so the proposal is of C
to secure land for the school and that
would be brought forward by the County
Council and its partners as and when
needed in their timelines but this
application would look to secure that
land and to enable that to happen if
needed an open space and the federal
grant extension again
so the spine mode this is the blue
dotted line this would be fixed so this
is the proposal that members would be
prima stage that they know in the
recommendation this spine right here
connecting the site I'm just to show a
little bit more detail of steel isn't he
round about going into the going into
the existing junction disrupt grade that
that Junction and here is that just a
little bit more detail now the timing of
this infrastructure the council council
have requested that this is provided
prior to commencement of any development
on site and this is the intention of
this would be to ensure that
construction traffic from this site
don't have to negotiate an historic core
wall pit and that can automatically
access the a14 with this new roundabouts
going in this is a significant benefit
of this scheme this would also provide
access for wall put business parks for
voyages and historic core because the
issue we have at the moment in warp it's
as if you want to get onto the a14 to go
eastbound
you either have to drive through the
village historic core or you go north
and cross over there 14 and they come
back onto it the other from the north
hand side and north north of the a14
both are convoluted and obviously there
was a traffic regulation order
restricting heavy vehicles going through
a wocket village so this this spine road
would be sniffling benefit to the
existing traffic and flows within the
village so here's some doctors are
showing if you're traveling from Elms
well into the new development that's the
the really who takes the new roundabout
so not my office or so this is the road
when you're coming up from the a14 slip
row so if you come from the a14
traveling westbound and you want to come
into warp it you will come up that's
Road and you can go south down in turn
will pit that way or into the spine road
which is where the doctors went and if
you're coming out at the spine Road
application site and want to go to the
a14 and eastbound that is the direction
that you would travel
so just looking at the access in more
detail just showing that roundabout is
to the south-west of the site and that
just shows if the highways proposals in
its entirety so moving on now to open
skate space and landscaping this stuff
shows the proposed development with
sight lines of the church I'll show you
some more photos in a moment to show the
existing sight lines of the church but I
think it should be noted that there are
no public access public rights-of-way
within the site at the moment and so
views of the church from where I'm
hovering here aren't readily publicly
available at present but you'll see from
the photos you do get views of st.
Mary's Church when you're on white L
name but the development has been
personally designed to ensure there is a
good gap between the development to
provide these long-range views to the
church so that it isn't completely
interrupted by the proposed development
I think it's important here to note that
obviously as we get into the heritage
harm understanding how development
impacts an asset and illicit building
it's not just whether you can see the
listed building it's not that's not just
the thing that defines the impact the
setting of a listed building is much
more it's about how the listed building
relates to its context its landscape and
it presents in Mary's Church it's
obviously tightly bound by development
to the South historic development as
well as more recent development but to
the north that has had a slightly more
agricultural setting although there is
some intermittent development which I'll
show you shortly on the slide all of the
heritage assets that I noted earlier in
Mary's checks since John's jokes and
albums well and melts close and the
conservation area the conclusion is that
there would be less than substantial
harm to the setting of these listed
buildings by the proposed development
I'll just run through there's a little
bit more with the photos and we'll weigh
those they that harm against the public
benefits when we conclude and there
datian suggest to go into a bit more
detail on st. Mary's Church here it is
shown whites with the application slight
boundary just shown partly down red
north and just to also refer to ladies
well the scheduled ancient monument in
wall picks and who got shown in red the
appeal site which was dismissed it
appeal by misled this applications like
is much further away from late as well
and the immediate setting of late as
well than that previous dismissed sites
this wanted to give that context in
relation to previous cases in open so
here we have the Church grade 1 listed
for a very good reason and one of the
key reasons the double hammer beam angel
roof inside the church which is very
good example preserved very example
under some of the details within the
church so just moving on to the plans
again there's a lot like more
information on character and density
that the application the applicants have
submitted here they show the different
characters just noting that's obviously
around the spy.road the with a certain
character with slightly denser
development and then the country edge
just respecting that more rural
development with open space that's
pulling the development back from the
site edges and a lower density scheme
I'll show you the densities on the next
slide and then just in the pink the
village greens open spaces and so here
we have the density again blue is the
lower density of 22:30 dwellings
particularly down here that's lower
lower density next the existing
development slightly more higher density
moving into the site and then when Rios
in the center of the site we've got the
35 to 45 dwellings for Hector just a we
will look at the hedges on site there's
a few slices to show exactly what's
there at present I think the key points
get across here is that there is some
hedgerow lost on site that the majority
of hair loss is species poor and there
was a net gain provision of hedge
hedgerow which will be species rich so
whilst some
being removed the overall the local net
gain of a better quality hedgerow by
replanting on the site so we'll just run
through exactly this is pre development
existing hedgerows and we've got species
rich in yellow species poor in pink and
then we've got the facts and figures of
what's to be retained and what's to be
planted but the overall figure is the
the total planting will be better than
the current offer so here we have a
yellow the new hedgerow planting I think
the next slide just shows a little bit
more detail over here we get we fade
fade to the arrow photography to show
what's there now cricket boolean a pitch
and then existing hedgerow and please
show this is new hedgerow to be planted
and this is the lost hedgerow here but
overall new hedgerow glancing exceeds
the loss and there will be a better gain
in the diversity of species that are
planted on the site so there's the suite
of biodiversity measures as well to
support the impacts to ensure we have
biodiversity net game which is our
requirement under the national planning
policy framework and this slide just
shows the great crested neat protection
area this area up here is not proposed
to be developed it's a landscape buffer
and ecology protection area which will
be managed in perpetuity to ensure that
creates that habitat and provides that
space for wildlife this slide here so
it's a lot of words but just wanted to
go some of the details of the
information the applicants have provided
on sustainability measures they have
provided a fair amount of information
which will help inform any renewable
sustainability strategy which is usually
subject to condition on outline schemes
but it just gives an indication of what
the developer has done on other schemes
and what they routinely do to help meet
the requirements for sustainability and
it is good to see that detail at this
stage we've like obviously would help
inform the reserve matters and the
any final condition details that we have
so we're looking at reduced carbon
dioxide emissions by the fabric the
building the air tightness using aerated
materials to make sure and making sure
they are sourced responsibly reducing
environmental impact of the actual
construction build its commitment to no
uPVC windows on sites only timber and in
technologies to try and widget reduce
use of fossil fuels or the different
renewable energy sources that can be
used here and then also site waste
management plan to make sure that reefs
and recycling of any wastes and the
site's was trying reduce its impacts
through the construction process so that
would be secured by condition Burtis
it's important to note that the
developers have fair have given a good
indication of what they intend to do at
this stage here we have some addictive
street scenes obviously the layout is
entirely for discussion there are some
fixed parameters such as the open space
the school site that needs to be
maintained and that the applicants have
given some potential street scenes this
one at the top left-hand corner so I
should have marked up the plan it's just
this street scene where I'm hovering the
point to the red points at the moment
that's just showing that landscape led
kind of having the space to allow for
landscape and within the scheme which is
one positive of this scheme there is a
good amount of space to make sure we can
plan in a good amount of landscaping to
soften the appearance with the
development and here was an example of
the open space planting and how the
development would relate to that so I
think the key thing to note really is
that there is there is space for
landscaping which is a key thing we need
to ensure at this stage to make sure you
get a good quality outcome at reserve
matters so now we're gonna go to the
photos we've got the photo points to
show you yellow here so at the top of
the application site looking towards the
remainder of the proposed emerging site
on occasion here we are looking across
the top of the site and then looking
down white owl mode
and then looking up the site with white
Elm Road on the left hand side and then
panning across the site looking at we're
currently looking at the landscape from
existing buffer that goes across the
site here so you can't see too much into
the proposed development site from this
point here to sanitation is we look
across the site everything crossed was a
14 but you can to see you can't see it
right on this slide but you can see the
entire grade to start Saint John's
Church sandeul's we also just points
that one out there so you do see this
developer site in the context of that
which is on the reasons that it's
identified this lesson substantial harm
to this the setting of that asset but it
is only lesson substantial harm given
there's quite a degree of separation
from that church to this site so now
we're just looking across towards the
landscaping belt and the center of the
site and here we've just got this file
which is a lot more visible of samaris
Church the South the site here we're
looking up where the landscaping buffer
and great crested newt protection area
will be and again it's looking across
centigram and this is view from the a14
just to demonstrate the difference in
levels and vegetation when you're
looking across to the site here we are
looking over at the site at the top of
the wider site allocation not our
application sites when you on the a14
over bridge here we have the slip road
for near 14 and approach roundabouts
marked on and that shows where this fine
road will be going round into the site
and just in the distance there you can
see st. mary's church spire just there
and that is first of all as you come
down the site here i think it's key to
point out here this this land here is
obviously not part of the application
site as the existing cricket ground and
then there is that buffer of land which
is going to be transferred to the cookie
Club just here and there's quite a lot
of the intervening landscaping and
before you get to the proposed
development and so here we are just
looking the opposite direction
where there's the phrase roundabouts and
spine road access would be this is view
obviously you would rarely have this
because this is looking out the back of
a car but you can see the church spire
there but as you arrive at that Junction
there you can clearly see the church
biosimilars Church and the application
site and just across the way there
obviously we have the cricket ground and
like I said before that's land to be
transferred to quick ground which acts
as a bit of a buffer to not interrupt
the setting of the church and this view
and now we're just looking at the
development of see what battle series
because we've seen the videos of the
site I think we've seen the streets in
quite a lot of detail in this
presentation already here we are looking
across the site from white elm Lane and
again need to see that church spire in
context of site which is why we've come
to conclusion that would be less than
substantial harm to the setting of the
church I think it's important to note
that there is that intervening
development both listed building and
more recent development that already
sits within the setting of the church
and it's not a fully open agricultural
setting but I'll see the wider
development site is much larger than
that intervening development just down
here but we concluded that this leads
the less than substantial harm to the
setting of the church so just looking
out right you go down were actually
laying back towards wall pit
applications like on our right behind us
and that concludes the photos so just to
run through the section 106 requirements
and then I'll get to the recommendation
and the balance officers have come to on
this site here we have all the matters
that will be secured through the section
106 who have affordable housing at 20%
this is lower than the 35% required by
policy but the applicants have gone
through a viability exercise which we
have had reviewed by the district valuer
and it's considered that the scheme is
not viable at 35% affordable housing
there was obviously a significant piece
of infrastructure going but the spine
Road and as a commitment to provide that
prior to commencement which is a good
benefit of the scheme but it obviously
does impact on the viability of the
scheme as we have seen through our work
with the district valuer
sorry back in other matters to be scared
through the section 106 contribution to
the land acquisition and bill cost of
the primary school obviously we have
land being skilled with primary school
that this development would need to
secure places pro rata for any
schoolchildren it generates so that has
been secured and also contribution for
early years at the same primary school
and the land of 2.2 hectares which is
acceptable to County Council as a school
site to meet the required planned growth
in the area also will security at space
and the village hall car park will be
secured in section 106 the burial-ground
extension and potentially the bus stops
need to be secured to the section 106 or
sale and but there will be securing
enhancements to public transport through
that mechanism and also one scheme that
I should have mentioned earlier was the
foot waste cycle way contribution so the
applicant has indicated and the County
Council have requested to a condition
that a foot way cyclist is secured from
the spine of the development to the
roundabout with the 1088 on the north
side of the a14 and that's to make sure
that there can be good access as towards
elms well through pedestrian cycle links
it doesn't transfer it doesn't run all
the way along the road into Elm as well
but there is a wider plan within the
infrastructure delivery plan that the
council has to divert funds to the
provision of cycle foot ways to connect
Wolcott and as well and this scheme
contributes towards it so it's a piece
towards that and obviously we need to
make sure that schemes mitigate their
own impacts we can't ask him to solve
wider issues within the fuller area and
it's considered that this this provision
is acceptable and the applicants are
committed to delivering it so to me
wants the recommendation photos I think
it's key to point out to members that
there is Harry Tom with this proposed
development but this is considered to be
less than substantial harm to the
Heritage assets listed which directs
assent
look to see whether the public benefits
outweigh that harm now this site the
benefits include provision of housing
the infrastructure the spirochetes will
be delivered at a very early stage which
will help the existing traffic issues
and take that traffic from certainly
more quick Business Park out of the
village directly deliver it to the a14
there's also the issue that one of the
key benefits the scheme is the location
of this development sits within a
sustainable transport corridor and
whilst it doesn't have a train station
at walpert itself it's in close
proximity to Elms well so they're over
we'll need to travel is reduced by
developing this side and if competitive
we're developing say a site much further
away in the district appreciate that
there's not a footpath cycle way exactly
into Elms well now but it is closed so
that the need to travel by private car
to sustainable transport corridors such
as the train station is reduced compared
to other sites so it is a very good
location which is one of the key
benefits of this cycle as well we're in
the situation where we've got
out-of-date policies so we have to make
the judgment as to whether the benefits
of this scheme outweigh the adverse
impacts for all the reasons that I just
outlined to be considered that those
benefits of the well located
developments the delivery of aspire Road
it's an early stage they all all assist
in helping those benefits be identified
and also the fact that this site can
provide a school site which is required
for the wider planned infrastructure in
the area to help the council deliver
that plan their growth once we get to
the point of adopting the joint local
plan these are all very significant
benefits in this site which are
considered to outweigh the harms of the
Heritage impact they lost served the
high grade agricultural land and the
landscape of that's all which are
outlined in the committee report so all
other matters such as surface water
ecology as our engine of course they're
all considered to be acceptable and it's
considered that the benefits of the
scheme outweigh the harms identify
I think just want to say one final thing
about the joint local plan of the
neighborhood plan I'll see both have
limited weight at present but I just
like to focus members minds on the
evidence base that has gone behind the
emerging joint local plan in finding
this a sustainable location for growth
compared to all the other sites that are
being promoted through the joint local
planet president I think that system we
can't place waste in the joint local
planet present but it is an indication
of the direction of travel of how to
achieve our growth requirements in the
most sustainable way so we have 69
objections to the scheme disturbed draw
the members attention to that but we
consider that this is the scheme that
should be approved for the reasons
outlined in the recommendation and page
40 of the QC report Thank You chair
thank you very much I think that gave us
a very good run round before I go to ask
members if they have any questions I've
just jot it down three I'm sure there
are plenty more but what was the time
the day of the video do we know that no
no I had a video it was during working
hours on a weekday oh that's all I know
like he knows and the schools they're
talking about giving schools will the
expansion go ahead at a current primary
school it's it's open to options at the
moment and the County have two options
they could either expand existing will
put prime school at present our
instruction every plan identifies the
site is landlocked but there is a
planning application in which is looking
to gifts land to the school to be able
to extend if there hasn't been
determined so we can't place any weight
on that coming forward at the moment so
we have two options if that all works
out more picking the extended but also
this does give opportunity for a new
school in warp it should it be required
but also I think Neil may be able to
explain exactly what the county's it
strategy is further but it certainly it
gives the option this school site in
this proposal and if the other site is
expanded what would happen to this side
proposed site I don't think it's it's
not certain at present and what would
happen
because obvious if you don't know but I
think the the planning application we
would look to have yet the the this
currently shows a school site if any
alteration work for that word to come in
it would need to subject just another
planning application because it ain't
has consent for schools life and just
one final thing and as I said there will
be lots of others I'm sure the car park
that's been suggested how many spaces is
that likely to provide it's quite
indicative at present but we have we
have asked the applicants to demonstrate
what could be and I think around 2020
cars is what's shown at the moment on
the indicative plans here so sorry about
that members up before I forgot
everything councillor Matheson but then
if members have it we can come down the
line so and does council of war boys
have any questions I'll give myself just
ask for a little clarification on the
options for the schools yeah to my mind
the rationale of having the Elms will
its own local school didn't world fit
its own local school rather than having
one large school that will fit which
will necessitate people traveling from
Elms well to world surely having to
there's a preferred option here isn't
them should we ask Neal to sort of give
us a Neil hello can we get you to give
us some sort of response to that being
the expert in that
please thank Thank You chairman and
Saudi I've got to my left feet monthly
works in schools infrastructure team but
in in summary that the broad strategy
for Elms will involve it is to expand
hell's world primary school from 315
places to 420 places so we can do that
on the existing site as as joe said for
wall hit the the current school has has
actually quite a bit of surplus spaces
at the moment so clearly we would look
to
fill that up with with any new children
from the development but then the the
school site thought from this scheme
would give us the opportunity to
consider what our options are now one
one option may be to further expand
Woolpit promise for the existing school
but having said that the the expansion
costs are extremely expensive so we're
talking probably about double the cost
of a normal expansion project so we're
talking about potentially over four
million pounds to expand the current
school so the option then maybe that
would be far more sensible to deliver a
new school that would then deal with
pupils from pulpit but also could deal
with some some children from from Elm as
well because in broad terms to have two
new small schools one and Elms well and
one in bullpit we just don't feel would
be viable in terms of educational sort
of good good curriculum activities like
so we feel that we keep keep to existing
skills and possibly have one new school
that would then deal with the growth
from from elsewhere and ball pit but as
I say this this an option if there isn't
a need for a new primary school then the
kennedy council clearly wouldn't deliver
a new school we would that the land here
is for the option and the answer so the
chairs come Tabac the the length of the
option we would normally secure the
education side for up to ten years after
the last dwelling occupation right I
think that was very clear thank you very
much councillor Matheson and if we have
you finished with that counselor wall
boys I think that was a very fulsome so
thank you Thank You councillor war boys
yeah if we could go to slide 37 that
that related to the basically to energy
and there are a number of attractive
items on the shopping list there now I
noticed that the the cot our consul tea
in
LT was concerned that the I think the
design and access statement something
offered this is these as possibilities
and in particular a 10% a 10%
improvement presumably over Part L so
you said in your presentation that the
that slide would be secured by condition
so is that we're now saying it we will
definitely get it rather than they'll
try and get it
I think we can say at present is that's
the strategy but then we need to get the
details through that so we obviously we
need to ensure that they they meet the
requirements of our policies and
obviously that 10% improvement but it
would finally be secured by by the
condition I think this gives a good
indication that they're committed to it
which is the the point I was trying to
make with this slide thank you I don't
Lee you've had the answer to the
question counselor so I don't think we
need to debate it that's that's the
answer at the moment councillor Turner
do you have any questions for the Lera T
yes obviously 300 houses and that
probably equates to a thousand more
people how is that going to impact on
their the health facilities taking into
account
Thurston's development as well because I
know it's under pressure as it is is it
going to be developed yes the health for
this site is it's been considered in the
infrastructure delivery plan offices in
the merging allocation and the NHS the
CCG would make requests through
community infrastructure levy
contributions to help meet that
requirement for healthcare but it's
identified no obstruction every plan
which has been developed through
discussions with the CCG that this
development it could adequately mitigate
its impacts by that sill contribution
and that would go to where the NHS would
need need the funding to provide that
health care so whilst we don't have the
exact strategy ironed out at present
although the infrastructures delivery
plan does identify
the doctor surgery that would take the
people from this development and there's
not any identified funding gap it's
certain that it could be it could be
committed to and provided so we're happy
that healthcare needs of the future
population of this development would be
adequately met thank you cancer Carter
any questions for clarity no Thank You
councillor Muller thank you
good [ __ ] can you please confirm whether
the proposed foot cycle path to be built
at the same time the spine Road in the
roundabout at the top of the slip road
off the a14 clip said its members of one
second I seem to be checking my file
what we do have yeah slightly ahead sit
quiet commencement the delivery of that
foot way yeah could you just repeat that
thank you it will depend on if it's a 2
7 8 or 106 contribution it's that's what
the delivery is but it's purely on
dependent on that but the condition that
we would put on this planning
application is before first occupation
of any dwellings that footway shall be
in place so that it would certainly be
in place with that council field any
questions for clarity no cancer a burn
yes
thank you thank you very much chair I've
got three questions if I may firstly the
the sites on it on a hill and I
understand this in key views from the
native land group and I just wondered if
you could confirm what those are
secondly can you confirm the distance to
the GP to the surgery from the site and
thirdly I'm just concerned about its
viability and 20 percent affordable
which is and does that viability
assessment include the site for the
schools of example if it wasn't there
with the viability just not have changed
thank you very much sure okay thank you
yeah they made her plan fine fine
slide for the key whew yeah the site is
is slightly sloping when you're
traveling along the streets the site
does fall away from you and when you're
on that road there are key views I think
the assessment of the landscape impact
that has been made to the planning
application is just see in the report
the landscape impact is considered to be
largely contained to some key receptors
around the site and the site isn't
highly visible to the surrounding air
reducing - meaning vegetation but there
are certainly receptors that will see
the change in the character of the site
let me just find the Dave her plan yep
if joe keeps I'm working on that I mean
there are as I understand it in the
neighborhood plan documents he presently
stands there's there's three key views B
G and D as I understand it and perhaps
it's best if I yes I've seen the
imaginary plan here we've got some key
views across the site just looking here
obviously it's not the nature at the
moment and that the development would
impact on those views but as I mentioned
earlier with the landscaping slide the
development is looking to be low density
they're different around the edges of
the scheme and have quite a sufficient
amount of landscaping just to soften the
impact so they are they are key views
identify the neighbor plan and they have
been considered through the planning
application proposal and consider that
the proposals are on the table show that
whilst of use they would be impacted
it's not to an unacceptable degree and
the distance the GP surgery I'm sorry I
don't have the precise figure I'm not
sure if anyone else then overlapping
three quarters of a mile and advice by
Sam and regarding the viability it's a
very good point about if the school site
is not required and that land has
released at a future date any section
106 agreement the affordable housing
part of that agreement would consider
would have a review mechanism in to make
sure that the viability issue beardless
the development goes ahead of
we would try to look to increase the
affordable housing offer if for any
reason that school site doesn't come
forwards
I will go to counselor heading him and
then come back to counselor field cause
he's thought of something
Thank You counselor had again thank you
that the footwear in the cycleway can
you share where that goes on the map
Thanks and also the width of the
pavement on the video we saw um I think
it was someone jogging but that the
paper looked very narrow can you just
tell us how wide that is
that's right why don't stretch picture
trying to see which plan best shows it's
basically the am footways from this
roundabout here to the roundabouts over
the other side of the a14 I'm not sure
I've got a better slide of it than that
at present is that sufficient to help
with the location or TT find fine
yeah the pavement and the application
science on leaf it's amusing for us to
go into obviously the pavement was along
here that's where we saw some running on
that narrow pavement see the application
site there's hedgerow and to be retained
and removed along here but it does look
it can have foot ways and within the
development site and I don't have the
precise specification as to what's
happening to that exact foot way there
but there will also be opportunities
within the reserved matter station sure
that there is foot ways through the
landscaped areas to make sure that
people can move through it along this
boundary off the site so whilst I don't
have the exact pavement size at present
I think the escape to improve the kind
of the pedestrian accessibility along
there as we go to the reserve massive
stage let's think we because we try to
achieve through good design of those
reserved matters and make sure the
possessions can move around the site
effectively thank you for that council
field we'll just come back to you and
then go on the top rope thank you just
the the issue of you're showing us land
use or proposed land use areas and
various layouts including some street
scenes but it's an entirely an issue of
indicative layout so none of that may
come to fruition at all I wonder what
sort of was you play something right
yeah I think the intention to of showing
those indicative street scenes was just
to show that the landscaping element is
possible because a good amount of space
has been provided for in the master plan
for landscaping I think I'll see ya the
the street scenes aren't set in stone
which is why I didn't show exactly where
the street scenes are we're in the
development because that's no certainty
that they'll come forwards but it small
so just to give a flavor of the the kind
of the landscaping the softening
of the appearance of the development
that can be achieved on the site and
because that space is planned in for at
this stage interpret life as it has
pretty low weight because it's really
just imagination I think it's it's it's
to give a flavor and to give assurance
is that we can achieve it at a later
date I think that's that's the point I'd
like to make sorry I mean I think the
point of these things that you would you
would not want to completely behind the
hand of a circumstance so that you
reserved matters are inflexible and what
I've seen done in other cases is to
phrase a condition that the reserved
matter should be in general conformity
with these details that that gives you
the flexibility to make sure something
is workable if something if a constraint
comes up but also seeks to secure what
what the principles are and that the
direction of travel it like that is we
describe within those so it isn't a
guarantee
I think bearing in mind that the
reserved matters are for another day
that's something that can be imposed to
give you comfort that they should as far
as possible as far as reasonably
possible to achieve what's set out today
Thank You councillor Gould thank you
thank you very much Jim my question
concerns the letter in the table papers
at page 13 from the corporate manager
strategic planning to them to the
neighbourhood plan group at that pulpit
and particularly penultimate paragraph
where mr. Hobbs's expressing some
anxiety I supposed to use that word
about the ability of the neighbourhood
plan to meet the housing requirement in
the evidence base of the emergent local
plan I just wondered and therefore
whether the plan would be able to meet
the basic the neighbourhood plan would
be able to meet the basic conditions
which is fairly fundamental I wondered
if there'd been a response to that thank
you
Chairman yes yes just just to confirm
the parish council wrote yesterday to
poor Bryant obviously it's not a
planning matter in the sense that it
concerns this application we've talked
about weight already today that responds
effectively if I can summarize
councillors and parish council do not
believe the submissions made by mid
Suffolk District Council Hopkins homes
and others have any validity that they
say that the joint local plan is still
in draft has no status and will be
subject to future change and they go on
to say that the joint local plan should
have been based on the neighborhood plan
allocations are I think the simplest way
of summarizing this is that you have
quite fundamental difference of opinion
on that point just so it become a little
bit more on the CD and the tension there
there is obviously tension that the
president between the JLP and the
neighborhood plan and that's something
that will play out to the examination of
the neighborhood plan it's not something
that we can necessarily really get into
today but again I just want to draw the
point back to our emerging joint local
plan looks at the district-wide needs
for housing requirements and there's a
large body of evidence behind that and
that's the difficult that we have to
play out where do we put the housing but
we're looking at the larger scale
picture with the joint local plan and I
think that's foresee that that tension
that needs to be needs to be resolved
councillor Carson do you have any
questions Kessler Hicks thanks can I
just talk about the roundabout so in the
recommendation can you just
it says details of roundabouts of State
Road and footpaths basically to follow
so who builds the roundabouts
because roundabouts are notoriously
expensive if the roundabout is comes up
with unknown problems can Hopkins Holmes
come back and change the affordable
housing which is a I think we've there
was a change in a different authority
something happened and they came back
and change the Affordable later so how
if the roundabouts start
building on the first day is the
affordable absolutely set so yes we're
looking to secure the roundabout by
condition it will be the developers who
are currently delivering that through a
section two seven eight agreement that's
the current mechanism to deliver they
obviously will have worked up the cost
of that roundabouts and factored that
into the viability appraisal which I
mentioned in touched on earlier the the
section 106 that secures the level of
affordable are identified that would be
signed and sealed and in place once the
decision is issued and then
understanding is that the that couldn't
be reviewed for a period of time after
it is signed and sealed
I believe it's five years so you'd be
looking at the situation of its it
wouldn't really be possible to go back
and try and reduce affordable housing
down due to costs of that roundabout
unless they delay the whole project but
then we're looking at I'll see well time
it sort of implementing the consent and
such like so it's it's it's I would say
it's less likely due to that fact that
you can't review the section 106 within
five years I'm being bullish instead of
being negative if house prices which I
read in the paper yesterday are now
booming and we start seeing a take off
in house prices and this is delivered
over a period of years is there any way
we could increase the affordable housing
because actually we find out that the
viability is
to negative yes we are looking at
putting a review mechanism in the
section 106 because we're not policy
compliant so there would be a review
mechanism to routinely review the
profitability of the development and
then clawback any money
into the affordable housing yeah that's
fine thank you very much indeed
everybody so now we will move on and we
just to let you know we have the Parish
Council and objector and the applicant
agent and we have one board member and a
statement by the other
remember so could mr. guy that please
come forward for the three minutes
please yes yes where of you like this
microphone comes on take your seat put
the microphone on and that would be fun
[Music]
I'm John Kyler Chandra will be parish
council will be parish council and the
people of Woolpit object strongly to
this application a three hundred homes
site will overwhelm Woolpit which will
return from an iconic Suffolk village
into a town its unique character will be
destroyed with some 900 houses in the
village already this site together with
others that have already been approved
would increase woop its size by 50%
although much of the traffic will head
for the a40 many vehicles will still go
into the already severely congested
village center and conservation area in
order to access local shops health
center school and other facilities this
site together with adjacent field and
are the same ownership with plans for
200 houses results at 500 homes as the
largest single site in the draft joint
and local plan inevitably if you approve
this application the 200 homes site will
follow the housing spatial distribution
proposed in the draft joint local plan
is contentious and has produced many
objections the housing spatial
distribution may well therefore we
changed a decision on this application
would preempt the very important debate
about the joint local planet a decision
on this site should therefore wait until
the JLP is a policy document whoopi
neighborhood plan is nearly complete it
went for public examination on the 7th
of February and should be made by early
summer this application of sanity is not
included in the house
sites that are proposed by the plan
although it was considered for inclusion
it was overwhelmingly opposed during
public consultation with enabled plans
so close to becoming a crucial planning
document the application before you
should not be determined until the plan
is made this is such a significant site
within both Woolpit
and MIT Suffolk that a decision on its
future should not be made without
members of this committee making a site
visit for themselves to see the impact
the number of houses that have on the
community I should point out chairman
that the video you saw in the
presentation is not typical of the
congestion you see in Wolcott Street
you'll have seen that green road is
closed from on that video so the amount
of traffic in the village was much
reduced so don't be misled by the lack
of traffic in the village on your video
and out point I raised slide 58 contains
an error the car park is not for the
village hall as stated it is a car park
for the village it's not a village hall
car park that's on slide 58 thank you
thank you very much two members have any
questions for mr. garlotte yes cancer
even thank you I can't share just with
regards to the primary school there's
some debate around whether the existing
school is due to be expanded expanded
could you enlarge on that whether you've
had discussions about the expansion of
the existing school we do not support
the idea of eligible children coming to
ball pit
Elms well should have his own facilities
for school to move children across it's
not correct we would like to see
initially the expansion of the existing
school but if that's not sufficient then
a new school is appropriate but not for
elves or sure as well that it's not the
way to deal with shorter for males
have their own facility thank you any
further questioning thank you very much
mr. Kyler if you'd like oh I beg your
pardon sorry John thank you Jeff um yeah
in your submission paragraph a nine yeah
you mentioned Norton would the view to
Norwood does that have a designation of
any kind Bobby for the officers or for
yourself
sorry do you have an answer of that it's
not something that was in any submission
I made its associated with the view
across to Elms well church and then
Norton would sits behind in the
background behind that and I'm hearing
behind me somewhere that listen SSA
sorry in fact yeah but it is behind the
Elms well Church yeah beyond well beyond
yeah okay thank you
and what was exactly once the question
was it for the officer or for mr.
Guillam I'm sorry yeah I was well it's
in the it's in the in the parishes
submission so I thought didn't we pass
oh right okay right thank you well done
okay if you now would like to return to
UC Thank You mr. garlotte thank you very
much
we now have mr. Moore hood please if
you'd like to come forward thank you
and if you'd like to press the button on
and then you have your three minutes
thank you Richard mall hood I'm the wolf
it resident and I'm chair of the
neighborhood plant steering group object
to this proposal on many counts but I
will focus on three firstly
notwithstanding any mitigation offered
by the developer there will be an
unacceptably severe negative impact to
the setting the wolf its conservation
area and grade 1 listed Church the view
of st. Mary's Church and its landmark
spire from the direction of White Elm
Road in the a14 bypass is at present
unimpeded the development of this size
in this location will damage the setting
irremediably the MPP F has a section on
this paragraphs one eight nine two one
nine two next wolf it neighborhood plans
landscape appraisal by consultant
Allison farmer stresses the sensitivity
of this site and its importance in
defining wolf its character and rural
setting on account of both outward and
inward views across this area she also
emphasizes that care should be taken to
keep new development close to the
existing edge that is a long very Road
only and to retain open fields between
the settlement and the a14 my third
point as chair of wolf its neighborhood
plan steering group I've been privileged
to carry out over three years of
consultations and evaluate the clearly
expressed wishes of the residents and
other stakeholders ninety-eight percent
of respondents to our questionnaire want
to protect
will its historic heritage and its
village character counselors chairman I
have not heard yet that the letter and
spirit of the 2012 Localism Act are dead
the prerogative of deciding that
question if it is thought necessary lies
outside the remit of this committee
hearing I'd like also to point out in
addition to what mr. Kyler said there
are other misrepresentations in the
planning officers presentation she spoke
of elms well station being conveniently
closed and would help to encourage
sustainable transport to work and other
places I would have to point out that
there is very little parking at
Ellsworth station and I am winding up as
she also made clear there will not be a
continuous footpath and cycleway in
spite of what Hopkins may provide all
the way to Elms well and its station was
very few buses how are they going to do
it thank you very much if you just like
to stay there I'm sure that the members
will have some questions and you'll be
able to amplify some of your points
so yes councillor Hicks think that the
cycler you've just talked about so how
far does it go to the railway station
as I understand it but you need to talk
to Hopkins they will provide a footpath
and a cycle way to the bridge over the
a14 on the other side there is nothing
there is no footpath alongside the road
so it is clearly not safe to walk to Elm
there's no cycle there's no cycle way
all the way from the other side of the
perimeter
thank you not at all can I just ask
I think other applications we've had
from Elms well there have been proposals
to assist with that are we any closer on
that could you help members to say how
that joined up it might get there
thank you there are requests for section
106 contributions to bring this to
fruition from other developments there
is also a desire from local transport
plan to be able to make funds available
to be able to bring this forward also
such brands as well
they have contributions to put towards
this like link councillor Hicks has that
answered your question do you have any
further questions yeah councillor
Matheson thank you yeah as countess's
raised that again I'd understood in the
presentation the the path would be by
this development the path will be
provided as far as what I assumed was
the roundabout the other side of the a
fall team with with the the 1088 and
Church Road roundabout as far as that
but it's now sounding as if it's only as
far as the bridge which is a great deal
less concern just expand on there we've
requested that the they contribute or
they deliver by building under Section 2
7 8 to the roundabout that's existing on
the arms or side of the O 14 thank you
for that it's really any scheme for how
it's gonna cross the the 1088 I've
cycled this a few times this would be
part of the future contributions from
the developers I said before from other
developments or from the suffolk county
council or sus trans but at present
we've just asked for at that roundabout
because we felt that was fair and
proportionate for the size of the
develop
that's coming forward I don't think we
need any more debate we've got the
answer to the question and how it
crosses will come at a later date I
think answer I'm curious to with you on
that one
any further questions no in that case
mr. Horlick thank you very much for your
time thank you we now move on we have
mr. James a flirt and Simon Bryan who
are applicants or agents and you have
three minutes please
Thank You chairman for the opportunity
to rest committee today
I am James all struck from bidwells and
beside me is Simon Bryan Development
Director at Hopkins Holmes I would just
like to say a few words about the scheme
which if permitted will deliver much
needed housing which respects local
housing need this will range from one to
four bed properties including bungalows
whilst delivering affordable housing and
wider strategic infrastructure for both
Woolpit and Elms well as identified in
the council's infrastructure delivery
plan during the preparation is planning
application Hopkins has consulted with
the Paris council local residents and
other stakeholders this consultation
informed both the scale of development
and the need for new primary school
sites and led directly to the inclusion
of a new burial ground village car park
extensions to the existing sports
pictures and a new spine road with
direct access to the a14 taking the
development traffic away from the
village center the scheme if approved
will also contribute as you've heard
earlier to a new foot way cycle way
leading to Elms well as members will be
aware the Wolcott neighborhood plan
proposes some housing sites but these
only provide around a third of the homes
necessary to meet the housing needs set
out in the council's draft local plan
following legal advice we consider the
current draft of the neighborhood plan
does not meet the basic conditions
required for the plan to be made nor
does it have sufficient regard to latest
evidence on housing need in both the
village and the wider district from the
outset careful consideration has been
given to the parish councils landscape
appraisal this resulted in the
indicative master plan before you
developing character areas with average
densities of 30 drawings per hectare in
Lima policy cs9 with areas of higher
density along the spine Road and then
lower towards the village edge I was
capturing long distant views towards
Mary's Church preserving the setting of
these heritage assets this is an
approach which has been positively
received by both historic England and
the council's heritage team Hopkins
towns is proud of its green credentials
and demands that its new homes are
energy-efficient and constructed to a
high standard sustainability key focus
of this is driving down energy demand by
increasing the thermal performance of
the dwellings this also involves looking
at carbon reduction measures which
include waste water and flue gas heat
recovery systems as well as PV panels in
addition the necessary infrastructure
for electric vehicle charge
points would be provided alongside a car
club card required by Suffolk County
counselors path any travel planning
measures in conclusion the the scheme
before is one which we believe
represents a sustainable viable and
deliverable solution to bring forward a
landscape led development which has
undergone extensive consultation with a
variety of stakeholders as you officers
outline development plan policies that
are most important for determining this
application are considered to be out of
date when weighed against the
requirements of the MPP F looking ahead
the council's emerging local plan is
proposing the site for allocation which
the material consideration of some
weight I therefore urge this committee
to approve this application in
accordance with officers recommendations
so that Hopkins homes may work out the
detailed design and start delivering
this high-quality and sustainable
extension to the village of Woolpit
helping fulfill both its housing and
wider infrastructure requirements thank
you thank you any questions
councillor Matheson thank you yes the
slide 37 again so are you are you happy
to accept a 10% better than Part L on
for the co2 as a condition rather than a
target which i think is what the console
team suggested was was all you were
offering effectively was a target rather
than a something you would absolutely
deliver yes simple answer a condition
requiring at least 10% would be
acceptable and I've just had
confirmation that that could be put on
as a condition should members be minded
and cancel it counselor had Ingham was
first and then council of war boys if
you would please thank you I'm do you
have a fixed idea of how many carpark
spaces are gonna be in the village
carpark is 20 opposed on the addicted
master plan although looking at the
layout there is scope
you know I think we're sort of led by
the the parish really in terms of walk
towards the ideal
counselor war boys next thank you and
then counselor even yeah just get a high
view in the sort of breakdown of
technology as you mentioned flue gas
heat recovery systems and that implies
that you you're proposing that the
heating systems will be gas based there
will be at the moment an element of gas
heating along with electric as well we
know often the governments pushes to
phase out gas on a lot of our
developments we we provide S or C pumps
so I think when it comes to that level
of detail we'll see what the energy
requirements are here what the energy
available e availability in the area is
but at the moment yes there will be some
some gas heating and the government's
proposed and I think this is going to be
phased out in 2025 that's correct that's
five years time yes yeah no was just
somebody I didn't know whether there was
a question for the yes yes please um
thank you chip Thank You chair thanks
very much that I've got two questions if
I may
you talked about the scheme reflecting
housing need yet you seem to have an
awful lot of three-bedroom properties in
the indicative layout so would you
looked at you look to change that and
also to increase the the affordable
substitutes well below our policy and
there's a group this is it is a
greenfield site and my second question
is that I'm concerned about the view get
from of the church from white el mode
didn't would you consider changing again
the addictive layout to provide for the
view I've seen schemes before where
they've kind of you know made sure that
the view is is is there remained thank
you it's just a close in you know what I
mean terms
the mix obviously it is an outline
application it is an indicative mix so
when it comes to the detail yes I think
it's better to say that we take due
regard to you know the local need there
is 300 homes you know there's enough
scope for a good range of property types
and sizes whether it be from Earth may
be a small amount of apartments to more
traditional housing to bungalows we are
regular providing bungalows within our
schemes now in terms of the the
affordable and you referred to as a
greenfield site yes it is but it's it's
far from a straightforward greenfield
site it's picking up on counsel a point
of view we have a very expensive road
it's not a crude dashed line on a plan
it is a worked up engineered drawing of
that road and hence we have a pretty
good idea of the cost it is a it is
approaching five million pound just for
that road we have got off to the seal
which we're estimating would be four and
a half-ish million hands addition to
seal as it's been outlined we've got
another one and a half-ish million
pounds worth of 106 costs on top along
with all the costs of delivering the
other the benefits of serving the school
site etc so yes it's a greenfield site
but there are disproportionate amount of
costs to to service that and there was a
and their views yes I mean where do you
take a viewpoint from you know we've
we've given due regards that coming off
of the the slip road from from the a14
the developers not impact on that
initial view we've selected a viewpoint
within that site I mean it could be
argue could take a few point from from
anywhere just to see the church it again
it is an indicative layout so there's no
reason why that viewpoint could not move
I think what we were utilizing the plan
for was to give members
Comfort that there is some commitment to
the principles of what's going to go
where I am just a conscious and I'm
saying we wouldn't agree to it that if
you're saying that people it's going to
move without any impact on where the
school site would go or where we're at
elements what elements would go so as it
stands and we're more than happy to be
committed under condition that the
reserved batter's would come forward in
board accordance with that concept plan
yes but I think the officer just wanted
to make one comment regarding conditions
no just to say the conditions listed in
the committee report one of them is the
market housing mix to be agreed prior to
submission as preserved matters all at
the same time as reserve masses and
that's specifically highlight to make
sure we get the the right market housing
mix so we'll be discussing going with
the applicants of that stage thank you
very much indeed
hopefully finished with questions for
the applicants thank you very much if
you'd like to return to your seats thank
you and councillor Mansell isn't here
but she asked could it be read out
before yours I don't know why but as
it's a long one I'm going to let the
officer have work I'm coughing a choke
on this because it's quite a long letter
I try to avoid both of those chair
please accept my apologies for not being
able to attend this meeting it was
arranged at short notice and I have an
important meeting in Coventry which I
couldn't look that could not be
rearranged this is an application for a
very large development in one of the
most iconic villages in the district
this development will irreversibly
change the character of Wolcott for the
worse most of the land is great to
agricultural land and is high-quality
land and as and this high-quality land
is in short supply and mid Suffolk there
are parts of the development which are
proposed to be up to 45 DPH which is to
high density for a village location this
is very much suburbia the wrong sort of
development this part of our district
this site has not been identified for
housing in the wallplate neighborhood
plan the plan is currently at
regulations 16 and the consultation
period ended last week
it is due to go to the inspector at the
beginning of March sir is there for
further evidence advanced than the JLP
alongside the provision of housing this
application also provides land for a new
primary school to accommodate growth in
both welcome soil and warp it this is
another example of development in the
wrong place
if housing proposals in also cannot be
accommodated by this existing school
then we need to be more flexible about
the size of the schools so we can put
one in Elms well not warp it although
the land is part of the allocation put
forward in our draft JLP the JLP does
not yet carry much weight and there have
been several objections to the spatial
strategy and this particular land
allocation this is not an example of a
plan load system the IDP part of the
evidence base for our ALP includes this
potential school site the amount of
proposed development does not mean that
there will have to be a new school in
this part of the district but there is
no evidence that it has to be in war pit
it just so happens that this developer
is promoting this site as a school site
this is an example of developer led not
planning led plan led planning sorry it
seems that the eat it seems like the
easy option we have no evidence that
other options have been considered and
the spatial distribution of housing in
the area is clearly unsustainable it is
unsustainable to locate a school for
elms world children in the neighbourhood
neighbouring village even if transport
is provided to get the ELMO pupils to a
school in war pit many parents will
drive their children to school causing
more traffic congestion at the already
overloaded junctions in Helm's well and
across the a14 roundabout currently
there is no safe walking walking or
cycling route between the two villages
the section 106 or section 2 7 8
agreement is only to make a contribution
of 220,000 pounds towards providing a
shared use path from this site to the a1
0 8 8 church
Junction there is no safe walking route
walking or cycling route from this
Junction into Elms well and there are
many HGVs which use this route to save
going all the way to berry to pick up a
one pick up the a one for three due to
the lorry ban on the a one zero eight
eight and of course the oversize HC
wilson lorries are on route to their
Depot in the north of Elms well I
certainly try to avoid walking along
Churchill there is practically no verge
and it is lethal and you and you are
suggesting children be walking this
route to and from the new school this
development and any future expansion of
the site will fill the gap between Elms
well and Wolcott and effectively
combined them to one large community and
this should only happen with the
creation of a complete pedestrian and
cycle route between the two communities
and where it is and where is any
controlled and where is any control
crossing of a new link road from the
shared use path on the north western
side of the road to allow safe access to
the center of Woolpit
the surgery and the other community
facilities from this path we need to
move away from a car based society and
promote more sustainable ways of living
this development provides a lot of new
highways infrastructure but only a
contribution towards the pedestrian
cycling this development should not go
ahead without the complete link if it
had to provide this then it would be
even less viable currently it is not
deemed viable enough to provide policy
compliant amount of on-site affordable
housing so let's look at the tie to it
tilted balance in paragraph 11 of the
MPP F which way does it tilt I know we
should be allowing development unless
there are compelling reasons against
doing so the compelling reasons against
this development are these are not the
right houses in the right location it is
suburban development in an iconic
Suffolk village the site is not viable
enough to provide
policy compliant proportion of
affordable homes it is not a sustainable
solution to the education provision
issues for the two villages we should be
retaining our high-quality agricultural
land there is precious excuse me
precious little grade to agricultural
land in our district there are highways
issues the new roundabouts are designed
with private motor vehicle was in mind
with insufficient thought about
sustainable modes of transport for the
occupiers of the new homes the balance
is therefore clearly tilted towards
refusing this application so I urge you
to refuse it cancel the ceremony so
thank you for that and we now have
counselor geek who can give us her on it
and we can ask questions accordingly
thank you very much councillor geek
thank you Joe could we have slide 14 up
again please it's not essential but if
you can find it that would be great I
would first like to say that I agree
completely with the statements made by
mr. Kyla mr. Morehead and council amount
so I'd like to explain why I think this
application should be refused to explain
the overwhelming harm that it will cause
to our village and why only benefits
don't out pray this our lack of ups to
date policies tilts the balance in favor
of sustainable development but you'll
have seen the parish council response in
your papers with the evidence that this
development is not economically or
environmentally or socially sustainable
and that the benefits don't outweigh the
substantial harms councillor Mansell has
described many of the infrastructure
problems the cycle path that stops
halfway around 12 the school in the
wrong place and in addition to keep this
development economically viable
it emits nearly half of the affordable
housing needed the contribution to the
cycle path is derive for a path which
south strands say will have to be can to
leave it out from the a14 bridge to make
it wide enough to as it crosses the
bridge so if you can't afford to build
this estate with all the infrastructure
that's needed to make it work you can't
afford to build it it's unviable . if we
can look at slide 14 you can see that
this is state in
increases the built-up area by over 50%
to built up areas that warp it over 50%
this huge development is out of all
proportion to the existing village and
that's just looking at these 300 without
looking at the other 200 that will
inevitably come to the north the science
is not allocated for housing in the war
pit neighborhood plan as we've heard the
parish council has consistently opposed
the inclusion of this site in the draft
joint local plan now both of those
documents are emerging but there are in
fact at different ends of the spectrum
that is an emerging plan the housing
allocations in the joint local plan are
in draft they have not yet been looked
at by an inspector they have importantly
not been agreed by all communities the
Woolpit neighborhood plan is it a much
more advanced stage mr. gajala pointed
out that many residents will drive
through the village center conservation
area to the village hall the primary
school and health center at the current
primary school the health center is
between 1200 meters and 800 meters away
from the estate and research dating back
to the 1920s shows that people tend to
get into their cars for a distance as
little as 400 meters I think those
distances would best be appreciated
through a site visit also that the
degree of slope the hills that you have
to get up but the development provides
easy access to the o14 in fact the
access is so easy that it will encourage
everyone to drive it'll be far quicker
to drive to work in Barry it's switch or
even Cambridge then it will be to cycle
to Elms well to take the train
particularly as there isn't a cycle path
as far as ouncer and there is actually
no official car parking announced well
there's little that you can use but
there's no official station car parking
for shopping well why walk to the coop
in the village when it's almost quicker
to jump in the car and drive to little
soar Sainsbury's this estate will be
more dormitory than community now
members may say that it's a residents
choice about whether they drive or
whether they take public transport but
it's our responsibility to make the
right choice also the easy the obvious
choice and here the easy obvious choice
is to drive and that isn't the right
answer the NPP F says that's to be
avoided and it's definitely there
thing when we're in a climate emergency
the entire site of 23 hectares is
located on grade 2 agricultural land
what the NPP F calls the best and most
versatile agricultural land the highest
grade of land that we have in the
district the NPP F says that planning
decisions should avoid the loss of grade
2 land the land allocations in the wool
pits neighbourhood plan take this into
account
surely this application should be
rejected on those grounds alone as we've
heard from the small herd harm will be
caused to the setting of the grade 1
listed buildings of both Wolcott and
Elms weld churches and those stunning
views that are identified in the
neighbourhood plan will be largely lost
you've all seen the views of st. Mary's
in the pictures you weren't shown a
realistic view of st. John's Church and
also and again a site visit is really
essential to understand this as the
listed buildings Act says a finding of
harm even less than substantial harm to
the setting of a listed building is a
consideration to which the
decision-maker must give considerable
importance and wait yes this can be
balanced against public benefit but
there's no public benefit in unbalancing
our village
building a school in the wrong place and
not providing enough affordable houses
the homes like the estate itself are
enormous in its long history this this
this massive development on grade 2
agricultural land destroying iconic
views of the two churches and putting a
new school in entirely their own place
it will be the worst thing that has ever
happened to walk it in its long history
please reject this application because
it would be a catastrophe for our
village thank you thank you
any questions for councillor geek yes
sorry
can we just go for questions for council
geek first no right so for the officer
off you go your turn counsel Peter Thank
You chair it's just that it's just the
issue of the grade to land that was
raised I just would like an officer to
confirm that in the relation to the MPPs
and also just we have confirmation whoop
it is listed his being in the kindy a 14
corridor and potentially in the draft
emerging and joint local plan you know
as an area for housing expansion but can
we just confirm that the housing the
spatial distribution hasn't been yet
confirmed in the draft JLP thank you
okay yes the application site is
comprised of best of the most versatile
agricultural land it's a mixture of
great two and three but we don't know
precisely its trail through a bit 3b but
certainly is best most versatile of
cultural land and this is obviously a
dis benefit of the scheme but it's needs
to be wade into the wider planning
balance which is also weaved into my
presentation that it's it's one of the
issues but then we're taking a step back
looking at the wider picture the
benefits of that sustainably located
scheme so it's something that we need to
undertake in the planning balance but it
wasn't considered to be fatal to the
balance that officers made in relation
to the special distribution strategy
obviously the GOP as it say it has
limited ways in planning terms I think
that's all we can say at this stage and
so yes we are looking at the growth
strategy identified this is an emerging
allocation and like I said before that
there's a large body of evidence that's
gone in to reform that but at present it
does have a limited weight in this
decision-making process I think that's
the safest thing we can say in relation
to your query on the special
distribution strategy thank you well
there we are
well oh yes counselor wall boards if is
this a question for cancer geek
sorry it's a question but I'm not
necessarily expecting the ward member to
be able to give me an answer it's just
about yeah but if it's a question please
ask and we'll see who can ask yes my
question is I mean hasn't been aired yet
it's about really about the Environment
Agency's response to this proposed
burial-ground extension and they quite
clearly maintain an olden objection to
the development has proposed and this is
because concerns over the aquifer I
think the officer will answer it for you
thank you yes this was a matter raised
by the Environment Agency through the
course of the application
I'll see you don't you want to make sure
that there's no contamination of ground
waters from the burial ground and the
last response from the Environment
Agency and they remove their objections
subject to condition on the use of the
land and making sure that there were no
burials within X metres of boreholes no
rails and standing water so they were
happy it's a rejection subject to
conditions on that land and they would
be imposed on the outline consent if we
just got the condition or no whereabouts
is that it's not their weekly certain
understanding no but exactly it would be
it would be added if it's not in that
list or perhaps even reading quicker
than me but it's a point that we need to
have considered you wish to come back on
that or if we got it you've got the
answer to the question I think yes I
think I've got the answer I just to be
clear that they the design the layout of
the development is going to be critical
on this the conditions by the
environment of our agency so I would
think the area of burial would to remain
is that correct yes yeah the Arabelle
would remain in that location I'll see
that's important that area there to not
be developed to keep the Heritage
impacts the conservation area
we've assessed it so the cemetery would
stay extension to cemeteries stay in
that location and it's just the location
of the burials within that ground would
be directed by the conditions that would
be attached to the outlined consent so
there would be a form of controlled by
the counts on that side of things to
make sure there's no contamination
chairman just just for clarity then I
think what we would propose up and I
can't quite pick that up in the
conditions list is is that we'd add we
would request by the anomalies yes
cryptic and capture all of the page
conditions for stability it effectively
would expect to have a strategy which
addresses that variable round land
contamination agreed before before works
proceed to dividend thank you do that
thank you for the question and is this
still a question would you like a
question or are you wishing to debate so
question carry on yes just about the
spatial distribution
I was wondering sort of status of that
person it's in our local plan but but
not yet agreed as that being derived in
some evidence-based way that proposes
that current split between the Ipswich
policy area of these villages or or is
it what should I say a figment of our
desires at the moment is it like me to
change
I think channel is about putting it this
that the strategies and its evidence
base is part of the consultation
document that forms the draft JLP and
the things behind it so without trying
to rehearse precisely what information
is we're about that it's a choice it's a
choice that's been made and the evidence
base behind that was and he is part of
the consultation document like
everything with a consultation I cannot
say that is concluded at this stage nor
can any other officer of the council
right so have we finished with our
questions thank you very much indeed
Thank You councillor geeks so we're now
open to debate if somebody would like to
start the debate off then
councillor Matheson well that's next
let's just continue let's just continue
the point on the spatial distribution
for a moment I was very interested to
read the the letter of the 6th of
February from mr. Hobbes to the
neighborhood plan or the parish council
people particularly the third paragraph
which listed the the basis the evidence
basis to field the evidence basis of the
spatial distribution that was put
forward alas only a week before the July
council meeting last year and the so the
preferred spatial distribution changed
the sense of exhibit ease and
constraints of the area of the
infrastructure capacity and somehow
these led to a change from what had
previously been considered necessary
across the district and spreading it
across around the district in these four
different areas a change which resulted
in wool pits number trebling and the the
percentage in the a14 corridor and I
think this is possibly not in that
somewhere else in the papers went up to
43% and and that percentage was higher
than any of the four options that were
offered at the previous stage so I
really do have a big problem with what
happened what evidence actually
supported that huge change that is a big
problem and council matheson is that all
you wish to debate on this because i
think we've got a lot of us and we're
not going to be coming backwards and
forwards have you got any other points
you'd like to make
well no buts about the planning
application before us I mean your
comment counselor Hicks thank you for
that well this is a difficult one for me
and I have to say on the one hand I see
some great positives I think you're
going to improve the infrastructure
through the through the village with the
new roundabouts and the access you're
going to improve the school facilities
in the long term and give the
opportunity for tent we've got that
we've talked about that 10-year period
and there is no doubt there is massive
demand for housing and mid Suffolk and
we know that and that's recognized on
the other side I you know we've got a
neighborhood plan coming forward we've
got a local plan this is a huge number
of housing for a very small community
you know this isn't this this is you
know I think counselor geek went step
further than I would but I do except
this is you know this isn't this is this
is this is changing the village forever
in a very significant way and the
problem I've got at the moment is I'm
struggling and maybe my colleagues to
find planning reasons and it's got to be
planning reasons rather than heart which
is where I'm at at the moment on the
reasons for refusing the application and
that is where I'm struggling it doesn't
sit comfortably with me I think it is a
huge amount of housing for a very small
community there are benefits but my
heart is telling me this is too big but
I'm struggling for planning reasons so
I'm going to listen I'm hoping some of
my colleagues can enlighten me further
but at the moment that's where I'm at
Thank You councillor Hicks who asked
what counts the field
yes I actually have similar views to
that I certainly find there are issues
here like the placing of the school
which one would really question
determining that children from one
village saw camellia which already has a
school so commute to a second village
which already has a school because she
wished to build a third one that seemed
to me a somewhat strange process and I
do on country look perhaps at the
highways improvements and if this scheme
is proposing and each large he does seem
to void benefits we know it's not going
to completely solve in any way the
congestion problems in the village
center but it would move substantial
traffic out of that area but I to have
some difficulty with the spatial
distribution of housing this is a very
big in with very big increase in housing
in this village I tend to ask myself
whether it's unusual when I've certainly
seen a number of other villages with the
same sort of numbers perhaps even with
bigger percentage increases in the
population and that spatial distribution
to an extent must be driven by what we
consider appropriate for the environment
if we distribute in those houses much
more widely around the district clearly
the use of private cars would go up
north down and if we seem to seek to
distribute them all close to your heavy
bus routes which have many buses on them
I'm not sure there's any of those in
Southwick anywhere but if we want to we
want to put them where we can use public
transport we get a very limited limited
range of opportunities so I certainly am
- around the position when I'll be
listening to what other people say and I
suppose have a feeling that I do have
some difficulty in finding
planning reasons for rejecting this
development thank you for that and as
you brought up that point regarding the
spatial distribution the NPP f we have
to review these things within two years
when things have been made so I suppose
that's going to be an ongoing moving
feast which would all become used to
however that's just a comment and bit of
knowledge there councillor Carter and
then councillor Yvonne please thank you
very much yes
mmm some very attractive points to this
development the road access the looking
at alternative energy the parking which
I'm assuming would have electric charm
point I didn't actually ask her at a
time I was mentioned right yeah choice
is it was they got some they're looking
at bungalows it just needed to be
desperately in mid sock work the problem
I have this seems to be a perfect puzzle
piece in the wrong jigsaw it's got all
these attractive points but it hasn't
got to be connected from roots hasn't
got B we'd be putting in with a footpath
and
a road with which goes to nowhere and
even once it's been put in we're looking
at it's not limited to no access routes
for make therefore lessor able to go
there wheelchair access and mobility
scooter access to you're looking at
non-existence going into the it's as it
currently stands if we're linking up a
school with two different villages well
again we have
or footpath routes we have involved the
access routes to go between we're
looking at speculative moments how we
possibly may be able to integrate it and
looking at getting money from here and
there but in reality we're going to have
buildings we can have school and we're
going to have the infrastructure there
without to be way of their joining it up
so we'll have as I said before we have a
right housing wrong place and it's going
to be bigger D just like my speech yeah
Thank You councillor Carter and members
are bringing up reasons of the schooling
and I just have a question I just wonder
if it could be clarified and also the
bringing up the reasons of the high rise
of footpath to nowhere it's so to speak
but it's got to start somewhere to get
there and there are other developments
that could join up the dots I'm sure the
schooling issue and this is a difficult
one if the school was to be built as a
new school what would happen to the
current primary school in Woolpit we're
only dealing with wallop it I'll just
ask that question Thank You chair can I
just give just a bit of fact
bit of factual sort of information and
big mumford to to my left is has
provided this so just a bit of context
to explain the current interaction that
happens at primary school level between
the villages are both eligible and
morbid so currently the Woolpit primary
school has 56 out of catchment children
that currently attend the school 23 of
those children are from Elms well
four realms well primary school sorry
and the ball pit so that's about third
of the children that attend Woolpit
primary school are from out of catchment
in terms of Emeril's well the current
number of pupils melted catchment is 52
which is about 20% and 17 of those
pupils attending ELLs well come from
ball pit so I think that just helps to
illustrate the help both communities is
interaction I'll leave that members to
to take come to yes thank you that
because obviously when children need
schooling they need schooling at the
time and not when the developments are
coming through but when today or that
looks interesting it's an interesting
thing for members to take into
consideration thank you for that now
I've got myself in a muddle who was next
please
somebody put their hand up I'm sure it
was calorie burn and then councilor gold
if you would please thank you thank you
very much chair I'm very concerned about
this reliance on the housing spatial
strategy that's in the emerging joint
local plan and its relationship to the
emerging neighborhood plan but also the
fact that no one's mentioned you know or
our existing local plan and our existing
core strategy of which some of the
policies such as safeguarding character
of conservation areas retaining visually
important open spaces provision and
distribution of housing you know some of
those policies need to be considered and
in this regard with this application
firstly the roundabout on Barry Road I
mean I'm not sure how necessary
it is and if it wasn't if we weren't to
have that round about could we actually
have more affordable Zhan this on this
site I'm a very very against any
application that has less than our
agreed policy of 35 percent on us up to
that if I represent 20 percent it's way
too low for a greenfield site even with
some of these benefits that are
allegedly in this application the views
of the church and we not go forever
there's there's that's gone you know the
views across from the direction of the
white Elm Road and as you come along the
a14 that's that's it you won't you won't
see that iconic building and you can't
get that back again the sustainability
of the site I would doubt it's no one is
from that sides gonna walk to the health
center they're gonna drive you know it's
just under a mile they're not gonna walk
all the way through the village back out
the other side similarly the school
which is beyond the health center
they're not going to walk to the school
they're gonna they're going to drive and
that is not sustainable the path twelves
well I think much more effort should
have been printed to doing that and
that's been discussed for years having a
cycle way in a path from orbital as well
and as yet to appear and we want people
to use the Train we don't want them to
drive we want to you know get out of
their cars it's mentioned about a bus
stop but there's no the bus services on
sufficient enough to service a bus stop
you know it was lovely having a bus dog
but you don't the bus services that are
very good and effective and get can get
people to work so I've got lots of
issues you know views of the church
particularly the the iconic setting the
past well most of all the lack of
affordable was the sustainability of
getting to the GP member school and I
just think this song is too big it's
it's in an iconic low
patient and it just yeah I appreciate
all the work that the applicant has put
into it but I just think it's not being
considered carefully enough within the
setting that it is and I do believe that
as many of our existing policies as well
as policies from the MPP F that can be
it should be looked at in this case
thank you very much chair thank you for
that councillor Gould if you liked it
thank you third chair i mean ii caught
between hearts and minds as others have
said on this issue in it matters of
heart ought to be us finding reasons for
approving the application because we
like it it works and so on but very
often mind is guiding us towards having
to find reasons planning reasons for for
refusal my colleagues would like people
have been involved recently in an
eight-day public inquiry but which
reasons for that the council's planning
reasons were for refusal we're tested
somewhat so i you know this for me will
turn on whether there are reasons
plenty reasons for refusal and i'm not
sure that we we have those available to
us here i am very sensitive to the
issues around the development of make of
the plan and the amount of work that
goes into that the application of
understanding of the place and people
making some investment in it in its
future and yes as the speaker said this
this comes from the Localism Act which
gives neighborhoods the opportunity to
develop a plan bit like all powers it
comes with responsibility and one
responsibility is to
provision adequate provision for future
housing need and there clearly is a big
gulf between the two emerging plans one
the neighborhood plan and the other the
the local a local plan so if I'm sure
that's very unclear where I am on this
but I am struggling to find the reasons
why we can refuse this application I
mean and final thing to say it is an
application that is not without virtue
it obviously does meet it does meet a
need it makes a contribution towards
infrastructure and my first concern
reading the papers was about the low
level of affordable housing provision at
at 20% I have a slightly better sense of
it now I think you've been aware of the
being made aware of the level of costs
associated with the provision of of the
infrastructure and I am comforted by the
fact that this is a matter that will be
continued to be considered and
unchallenged where the process to
continue thank you very much yes that's
a very interesting point your last point
in particular the whole lot was very
interesting of course but that was an
interesting point
councillor Caston please then counts to
know that if we would Thank You chairman
yeah I'll explain where I am at the
moment because warp it is a key service
center it's a huge change for this
village and I think I'm always very sad
when building goes on around a church
especially such a unique one however
there is some building in rectory Lane
and Mason's Lane already that's
surrounding it but of course not the
spire
this I believe would would take the
spire out of them view I don't like the
large increase in the size of Woolpit
but a small percentage of affordable
housing it's just over half what we
expect from a development this side but
like other members I'm really struggling
to find clear planning reasons to refuse
I have in my mind that an appeals been
successful the other further away from
the a14 in you know you know further
into the village and I looking at this I
think it is more sustainable than a lot
of development with the new roundabouts
going in but I remember as year perhaps
members here could and help me out with
material reasons that will stand up to
the Secretary of State scrutiny if we do
refuse this application and I listened
eagerly to the debate for those thank
you
I can certainly emphasize with the the
residents of Woolpit this isn't a very
large development I do agree with
councillor geek and character even that
people will travel by car for even the
shortest distances regardless of whether
there's a footpath or not it is
disappointing to hear that the proposed
foot cycle path literally seems to go
just the other side the a14 though is
soundharya desi are there is a
possibility that there may be sort of
106 payments available from the elves
well site to actually connect it through
that is a very positive thing but then
again I don't think that will deter from
people actually using their own
transport there are some other good
things noted in this that the potential
for more sports pitches there is Jenny a
shortage of sports pictures in the
district and I know that from having
sort of conversations with the Football
Association of suffering etc so that's
another welcome thing
I do agree that the 20% provision for
affordable housing is very low however I
accept that following the the applicants
points regarding the amount of money
that has to be spent on the roadworks on
the a for the roundabout and the link
road I can understand that but I'm still
sort of sitting on the fence on this one
I do actually find this one quite
incredibly difficult just to think about
spatial strategy I think it was just
gonna give us a bit more information
Thank You Johnny yes I mean this this
forum is not the forum to debate the
spatial strategy you know the
consultation on JLP and its
testing is a separate matter the
important thing here though is that you
have to work on the policies that you
presently have and I think the reasons
set out in the report in paragraph 3.2
and following most of the key housing
policies for spatial distribution which
are relevant to the determination of
this application are treated and have
been treated regularly by sector of
state inspectors on fairly sizable
appeals as being out of date and that
will continue to be the place for as
long as we do not have a plan in place
so to that extent you know we have to be
very clear that the NPP F is the policy
document that should guide decisions and
the presumption in that is that there
will be a significant boost to the
supply of housing and against that I
would urge you to consider very
carefully how that plays into your
weighing of the policies because we
cannot rely upon the core strategy in
the core strategy focus review for a
spatial strategy which seeks to provide
housing aware where we might otherwise
prefer it thank general so we've and one
other point just whilst we're at this
the viability aspect and the concern
regarding twenty percent affordable
that's offered within the scheme I would
say this the access road and roundabout
as major items of construction are
having to be forward funded within the
project time scale here and that in its
own right is a cost burden within the
scheme which has to be taken account of
were that to be delivered later on that
might be a different position but
because it comes early within the scheme
it is therefore an important
consideration to you know the financial
mechanics of the project now have week
before I go to councillor Matheson wants
to come back again and councillor Carter
is there anybody who hasn't spoken who
wishes to speak and of course I'll wait
until the end anyway cancel a war boys
would you like to speak in the debate
please you haven't spoken yet just as I
said I think there's a lot of
conflicting issues here one is the
conflict if you like between the local
plan and the neighborhood plan I'm not
concerned as a conflict it's gonna be
discussion there but it's a scale five
and five hundred houses proposed on La
zero-nine-five
of which 300 is in this development the
school issue is one where I think
there's an argument perhaps not to be
made here between small communities
schools which expensive curriculum
deliver expensive in terms of delivering
the curriculum against the costs of
planning longer journeys for more
children again that's a nugget to be
made I think the the other carrot is
perhaps the graveyard which may or may
not be very usable depending on the
environmental agency reports I'm not
convinced about sustainability of this
development from the transport point of
view and the impact on the community
iFit seen as 300-plus a further 200 down
the road
think la Oh 9 5 as a site it is
questionable it does it is a clear
expanse of valuable agricultural land
which will be lost
it's great to for which there's not very
much of it in mid Suffolk which means
that some more flexible more useful land
and again that affects the sited of the
historic buildings and I think there's
also I'm very concerned about the 20% of
the only 20% of affordable housing which
doesn't really help the local community
in fact they've looked at the
species-rich head row between this in
the site now at the present this is in
the boundary between this development
and the rest of LA oh no five the fact
that it's separate from the roads is
perhaps White's species which had row if
it becomes a boundary of the development
site and then enclose within further
development I think the environmental
impact wouldn't really be acceptable I
think that's about Oh
I'm not convinced that this is the right
scale of development in this site it
will have a sustainable impact on the
community and the environment right
thank you for that cancer now before we
move to having second goes of this it's
very unusual I think has everybody
spoken who wishes to speak for the first
time it is unusual from the chair that I
would normally speak at this point but
it is such a difficult one that I feel I
could make comment myself as many of you
know I lived in war pit for 15 years
admittedly that was 28 years ago and it
was when olds so Market Road passed
through the center of war pit and it was
the old a 45 so yes I have got a few
more gray hairs
I should have and I went there when they
just opened the a full team with the
dual carriageway and the difference was
noticeable of the traffic but then the
traffic then wasn't as much as it is now
and I've listened to everybody that's
speaking now and I think we're all torn
because this is a huge amount of extra
homes the the positives on it which I
look at and I hear to some of the
objections with it is that this spine
road will actually hopefully lead a bulk
of the residents out of the center of
Woolpit and I hear what people say about
they won't walk from there to the shops
or to the health center or to the school
but to avoid the pinch hidden points in
Wolfe it they could use the spine to get
out and come round I also hear the
footpath and cycle way which has got to
start somewhere
and we can't just keep saying well it'll
never happen I'm encouraged by what's
being said of contributions towards
these things and I'm also as curious as
councillor Matheson is on how do you
cross that road at the end because
believe me I used to ride horses ran
that roundabout up killing Lane and up
round Elms world but there wasn't the
traffic there is now but it is a
difficult Junction so that needs to be
taken into consideration but that's from
other developments coming forward
bringing the funding the school issue I
think I'm encouraged by what I'm hearing
about it
from the point of view it's such an
interesting thing that half of them are
there now and half of them aren't so a
bigger school could be an option and
that's always on the table it's the size
of this and the number of this that
worries me greatly for wool pit
I love little pit and I've got some
wonderful memories of when John Gorman
was there at
at the bakery there and it was such a
lovely community I've got wonderful
pictures hanging on my wall of the pump
and things like that but the heart of
Woolpit won't actually change with this
development were not actually building
in that part there have been sporadic
buildings going on there it will have a
benefit of keeping the industries which
actually it's marvelous that whoop it
has all these employment opportunities
within it and within a near space to it
and hopefully it would take traffic away
but unlike everyone else struggling to
try and find a reason to refuse this so
that's where I am with you all it's so
difficult and I would now like to come
back to those people who would like to
have a second go at this councillor
Matheson thank you yes I didn't go into
the substantive detail on my first
comments just making that so putting
aside the space with strategy issues I
think the the account that Carter has
said you know it's actually a very good
development
I mean much better than one we had on
Wednesday for example in terms of making
a real effort on on the on the energy
front which is which is good however the
we've got some heritage harm that needs
to be outweighed by public benefit and
we've also heard that we've got the
great - agriculture alone which is quite
rare and I think the what hasn't really
been talked about quite specifically is
the the social the three legs of
sustainability if we just look at the
social leg of that for a moment then a
50% expansion of a village and that's
without the extra 200 that's just 300
and the other ones that have been
approved and so on
you know socially that is not something
that you can just integrate into
a cohesive current community of 900
houses so that that's that's a - as far
as sustainability concern the social
sustainability so if you look at the
benefits that are are offered to to
outweigh those various bits of harm then
we're getting we're getting some more
housing but well we've got four thousand
odd planning permissions already banked
outstanding and not built yet which is
you know a huge figure so there isn't a
big big benefit in getting a few more
and also on the housing and social
benefit we're actually losing forty five
affordable 's right in the jaw from from
thirty five to twenty we lose forty five
affordable homes but what are we getting
exchanged for those we get two
roundabouts and if you start talking
about sustainable travel then we're
putting all that money into two
roundabouts and and also a school which
is actually not in the right place it's
in the wrong place so I think that
there's there's quite a lot of problems
of you know but the benefits are flawed
let's put it that way and clearly that
the the I've got a concern that the only
half of that path is being provided and
if the path was all there then there was
enough of the path already that this
this would development be able to
deliver the finishing of it and then you
can say well the two villages are
connected sustainably this is great but
unfortunately it's it's not it's not
what's available so as I say I think
that is the crucial thing to me is that
the benefits are flawed each of the big
benefits are flawed and and so you know
that's that's what I think at the moment
is outweighs the you know it does it
doesn't Foley fails to outweigh the
harms
answer Carter yes I just thought to ask
members just what about this development
makes it so attractive is it that we are
we need to provide more houses mid
Suffolk which yes we do but who are we
to provide houses for just for those who
care for money to afford them or are we
trying to provide for money of houses
for all for all of society back in if
you might you need them so we're looking
at it's gonna cost them money so you
need to put in a roundabout and and
vehicle access
well yes bigger this could cost them
money because they want to put over
development there which it wouldn't cost
them money if they work that trying to
put houses in the area which they don't
release it one of the houses they're
late really it's the baby not the right
type of houses the right place so
they're gonna put in the road access
they're going to you make it more
attractive to drive today to be we're
making it less attractive to walk or
cycle this is not actually a providing
anything to benefit there and also avoid
brought up here the species we are at a
moment facing a climate crisis we're not
just facing the planet crisis we are
facing in the ecological crisis but
about areas currently it's a species
rich for pre breeding for skylarks it's
got deserts period in 14 of the nineteen
British species including additional
backs which has just recently come out
to decline they currently use we
hedgerow as a bereavement counselor
cotton I don't mean to sort of in
disrupt your flow but there are
mitigations in there for those things
I'm just wondering if you can offer us
something more to the debate of how we
go about saying yes or no I know you've
you're passionate on
on those issues and it is important but
these have already sort of been looked
at and they've got mitigations for them
I'm wondering if if you're saying there
isn't sufficient is that what you're
saying wait wouldn't Sleepy mitigations
our education efficient because how are
they going to mitigate the disruption
whenever Aviva raid access to be put in
how they going to is the development
only going to be taking place within
months where the breeding habitat of
approve the bats are not going to be to
tape up are we going to be talking about
increasing be hedgerow by planting but
without read about the disruption of a
hedgerow how that is going to affect
species currently there we are looking
at possible decline of five years of a
by this disruption by making it unlikely
but these are the habitats will be used
in that a bit in that time so yes it's
wonderful that we're looking at ways of
mitigating it but how are they going to
prevent the damage taking place in the
first place I wouldn't need to mitigate
these circumstances if they were leaving
it alone chairman if I can just clarify
what's in the recommendation on page 41
I think once you've got past the fourth
bullet which is about phasing you've got
a suite of conditions which relate to
ecological issues including a submission
of an ecological construction
environment management and I think
understanding that construction works
can be disruptive to biodiversity
interests I think the purpose of that is
specifically to face and deal with that
specific issue that you described and
obviously there's a sequence of other
biodiversity and ecology based
conditions which follow on from that
because this is obviously an outline
application I think because we've got
where we've got more all stalling on
this and we're having great difficulty
one of the things that is coming out of
everybody's views is they're very
disappointed with the
affordable number of properties and
we've heard from the applicants of the
costs that they're having to incur to
put in the roundabouts and the road
structure and the spine structure and so
on
and I just throw this into the mix at
the moment that nobody's really come up
with any reasons that we could refuse it
on so we're going to have to look to
being approving it but I just wonder if
we could ask officers to go away to see
if they could seek an improvement on the
affordable homes which might deliver a
better public benefit which might tilt
one or two of us to sort of become don't
that what we're doing if we recommend
approval might be more palatable I just
wonder throwing that into the mix
whether that's some way if not can
somebody make a proposal from the floor
can't sorry bone first thank you sir if
I could just come back on the previous
points I just would like confirmation
that within our existing local plan and
our core strategy there are various
policies such as retaining visually
important open spaces safeguarding the
character of conservation areas
retaining high quality agricultural land
etc just I would like confirmation
whether those policies still stand but
secondly I would say that this
application does not meet several of the
NPP F's requirements the use of land
section 11 of the MPP F an appropriate
densities doesn't meet that section 9 of
the MPP F regarding sustainable
transport I would far rather see a swap
of around about four cycleways and so on
section 16 which is conservation of
historic buildings and protecting
conservation areas in the NPP F so it
doesn't meet that either so there are
areas that this does not this
application does not meet but within our
existing policies there are a lot there
and I just would like confirmation
whether they those still stand from the
our local or existing local plan and our
core strategy thank you very much chair
thank you the yeah the policies in the
local plan I'll see some a save some a
current but once you fer to approach
will land protection of heritage assets
they certainly are policies that we
still give wait see and stay these are
matters which we've raised and conflicts
that we've raised in this planning
application and de'cine as dis benefits
so yes that's where the the assessment
of heritage is she being a harm comes
from and also the loss of agricultural
land is based on our policies so yes
they very much are relevant
Castlefield you know I perhaps ask the
question I one of the key things that's
obviously concerning this all is the
percent the increase in housing in the
war period the percentage increase if
you like I find my memory of the number
of houses image suffers a little how
easy we are looking at putting in some
10,000 houses within the period of a
local plan and I am unsure whether we
have thirty five thousand at the moment
or was it somewhat higher than that
forty one thousand that clearly drives a
twenty five percent increase if the
houses are uniformly distributed so for
every four house cluster we need to put
in another one and if we choose that we
won't do that for environmental reasons
more than anything because of the
sustainability of transport we're going
to compress those houses into relatively
few locations towns the small towns we
have the key service centers inevitably
we're going to be faced with a
substantial percentage increase in those
villages so to an extent we're trying to
I know what we're trying to do try to
discuss it until the problem goes away
there is inevitably a problem there and
I'm certainly aware of areas County
divisions where perhaps is a 57%
increase in housing across the entire
area and I won't tell you whose County
division that is so the you know there
is a problem here which somehow we have
to resolve and the local plan is trying
to resolve it in a way that inevitably
we don't like when we see each instance
of that so I don't know where that helps
our thought process forward at all but
it there is clearly an issue there that
we can't argue our way out of
simply unless the numbers in the local
plan are incorrect
thank you for that John and it is a an
interesting conundrum counts the gold
let's start with the thing upon which we
can all agree that this is a difficult
decision I mean even probably rather
wish we didn't have to take it but we do
it's our responsibility so to do I come
back to this point about having
substantial planning reasons for
refusing the application and this has
been well well discussed good questions
put and I think answers given them
indeed there's there's a great deal
within the report itself and the
background papers and I see nothing I've
feel I've heard nothing to really gain
say the officers conclusions and advice
though that is something that we often
find ourselves doing but on this
occasion I find no reason so to do so
I'm going to venture that proposal that
we accept the recommendation of the
report thank you for that counselor Gold
is there a seconder for that particular
recommendation yes I casted yeah I'll
second that
but is reluctant I know so is there
anything else anybody else wishes to say
sorry counselor Carter yes yes I do have
a general query about regarding the
necessary for this forum in as it turns
out we can only turn things down on
planning reasons
well why debate it in the first place
but we could just have a computer say
going for an algorithm of what we put in
as policy and Vince to answer would be
mid Suffolk wants more houses let's say
yes we are here we are counselors we are
representing four communities but
available for us we are representing the
electorate we are not here to represent
planning policy we're not here to spit
out rhetoric and just to go to argue all
this time
Mingo say well we've got nothing to say
no one we are here socially say this is
this is were on we can see it's wrong
none of us want to bigger to prove us
there must be a reason for it so why are
we here if we are here it is a human
element to say that we don't like none
of us like this development is not in
the right place it's not doing the right
things
well what why are we here if we can't
say no to it we've always said we don't
like it also that it given the reasons
why it's wrong so what was the point
enough so being here and wasting these
people time having to come to it switch
yeah I think you've made your point but
the thing is we have to have legal
planning reasons for it can I just ask
the officer to I was just gonna sort of
reply in part to caps the Carter's
comments that the Planning Committee is
here to be the transparent body so that
decisions can be made in this case it is
apparent so far from what I've seen from
the debate that members are an agreement
on some parts but it's mr. Isabel and as
the law suggests on all cases of what
we're doing today
that it has to be dealt with in a legal
matter and has legal planning reasons
that's why we go about these decisions
I wouldn't say in essence that members
do not have an seriously important role
in decision making
as we see on many of the occasions that
counselors are here to put specific and
very important input into decision
making process and to this is part of
the democratic process in this case I
think it is there are some very
important points that have been made in
the debate and I think that's I'll leave
it there Jeff Thank You Jamie
yes in essence in my time in in my
career I have seen many planning
committees deal with difficult
applications and it is never an easy
proposition whether that application is
a small or a large matter the end result
is that it is about transparency of
decision making but one cannot avoid the
irresistible considerations that present
yourself you you have to approach this
by looking at the weight that you attach
to these things and approaching these
matters in a in a way that the law
requires planning is not black and white
there are huge permutations of grey and
in my experience the role of committee
has over many years been to add value to
officers deliberations sometimes to
provide challenging reasons to defend an
appeal but always that debate has I
think produced what I would say is a
thorough scrutiny of the exercise and
save for that most of the decisions will
be made under delegated powers and my
question whether one would simply
produce an algorithm to do that for the
most difficult decisions there is no
doubting that these things require
debate and careful consideration they
require you as a committee to weigh up
between different and often competing
considerations and there is no
black/white answer what I can tell you
is fact though is that the Secretary of
State stands ready to decide appeals and
in my experience it is usually the case
Secretary of State's inspector will tend
to give one less than one might achieve
were one to see an appeal decided an
application decided locally nonetheless
doesn't make these things do easy and
one must get that consideration right we
as officers have put forward papers
which we think reflect a reasonable
balance it is not the only balance that
you might draw here and so counselor
Carter wanted to come back and counselor
Matheson again please if we can draw
this so it answered to my question but
the reason we're here is to be shaved
transparency well we're being quite
transparent that we have members have no
say because we can argue about it but we
was fall back on what was law can weave
in as a forums it stand up for advice
say okay we can a it's likely to pass
but this is wrong we as men we can see
it is wrong but excuse me counselor
Carter you can actually vote that way if
that's the way you wish and you can then
put the proposals forward if it if the
vote falls so I think that sort of
counters your argument we've dragged
this out quite long enough now and I
think we need to come to a conclusion
one way or the other so I'm sorry
counselor Carter to cut you off
councillor Matheson you know I just just
wanted to remind members especially
counselors golden field that the the
overall district-wide objectively
assessed housing need with which we're
wrestling with let me talk about spatial
strategy has actually got a twenty
percent buffer in it so that that's the
numbers are a bit bigger than perhaps
they might be by their extent thank you
for that well then we have a proposal on
a second on the table
so remembering that if it's refused we
need some planning reasons so all those
in favor please vote
can you count again make sure you're
clear on this two three four five so my
gradient seven and those against by so
the motion is carried
thank you and thank you very much
everybody for the input it's not been
easy at all and everybody's input was
much appreciated I don't have any site
visits proposed and so the meeting is
now closed
you